again the nature of flight is freedom
but true Freedom comes from discipline
and accountability bar
we should stop there
the North Koreans came pouring over the
38th parallel This Is War and we're up
Jesse
Leroy Brown
um I view him as a Trailblazer I viewed
him as a citizen in spite of given
circumstances of what it was to be a
quote-unquote Citizen and a black man in
America at the time but he's an American
he's a father he's a son
he's a husband and he's the first black
Naval aviator I think his approach to
life probably lies in
the parenthetical of the Trailblazer
where
you know there's stories about him where
for instance he married his wife without
permission he went to a church
he said to the church I need to marry
this woman I gotta have her with me can
someone house her you know uh and and
and and and and and keep her you know so
we can be together
um while he was doing his training
he he brought himself from the mud to
the sky and became the first which was
not a thing that was uh possible at the
time obviously I think he his point of
view on life was uh access he was driven
by uh getting access into school uh Into
His Highest Potential into being the
best father being the best Aviator being
the you know he he he believed in his
capacities more than most people and did
what it took via Devotion to those
things to achieve that in terms of
getting to know Tom hudner as a man to
get the rights to this book and and his
life rights I had to meet him and talk
to his family and essentially get his
Blessing you know to to
and convince him that I was gonna you
know be able to tell the story and tell
it right and one of the things that I
realized that Tom was was a guy who he
was such a well-intentioned guy he was
from a a place where he wanted to be
um he's just so good-natured and he
wants to do the right thing and one of
the things that I find to be kind of
interesting and compelling about people
that want to do the right thing is
sometimes you want to do the right thing
and there is no Battleground to do the
right thing right
um You don't know how to be a good
person when there is no fight in front
of your face and I find that what I
think that when I was trying to embody
Tom hudner is he was a man who was
looking to do the right thing and World
War II had passed his his Heroes the
heroes had been made and there was no
war in sight and there was no bad guys
to fight there was no way to define
yourself and one of the things I found
really compelling was that the story The
Arc of the character is that he was
looking to Define himself and his
it came true and just not in the way
that he had hoped it's actually he lost
everything by getting what he wanted and
what I found to be really interesting
and poignant in terms of where we are
today in terms of why I think this is a
very topical story is there is a
Battleground to fight it may not seem
egregious but right now more than ever
it's very important to not fight your
own fight but to to look up and and make
sure and be you know an ally to be a
wingman and to put your skin in in the
game for for the people you love I feel
like that's what defines Tom and that's
where he found I feel like Solace and
and companionship and a soul mate in
Jesse Brown is Jesse Brown is a man
who's always had a fight and he's a he's
a guy who's been through the fire he's
come out the fire and and every day he
reminds himself that he's come through
the fire and there's more on the other
side uh and when you pair those two
Flames together it becomes Cosmic it
becomes fate and it becomes Eternal and
and that's a relationship that's that's
lasted generations for a reason you take
it how many times people have told me to
give up quit
I even
uh that's why you can't always do what
you're told what do you want me to do
just be my link man I I will say that
the planes were the least of our worries
with this one Jonathan Majors can grunt
his way through just about anything I
mean he's one of the toughest people
I've ever met in terms of the emotional
pressure I think that's they're way more
daunting than geez
um and I think that's one of the things
that we approached every day was never
to skip a moment an opportunity to do
this story right there's a million ways
to do it wrong but the truth is a narrow
Target and a hard target to hit but if
you hit it it it it it it lights the
world on fire and and that's what we
were trying to do with this thing and
that requires a lot of attention it
requires a lot of focus
um and that focus and that tenacity is
something that Jonathan majors has in
Spades JD Dillard our filmmaker is is
he's a he's the son of the second
African-American Blue Angel a guy who is
so passionate about Aviation but also
watch what his dad did
um and and I I will say that the hearts
are on Celluloid in this movie in a
really beautiful way and and everyone
um just cared we showed up to work
no days off everybody cares you know no
days off and it's like that's that's
that's what makes this movie different
that's what makes this movie different
is this is not just about capturing
something cool on camera the emotional
weight was the daunting aspect but also
the fuel in our tank that kept us going
yeah I mean I have the same answers so I
would just piggyback you know the
specificity of the life the lives of
these men and the time period was
extremely important and and and for me
and I think ultimately for us that was
the story
um that was the story and because these
men lived
it truthfully you know in that time
period and and their legacy is now you
know on display there is a certain
amount of obligation to get you know the
life of these people out in these you
know two hours and 11 minutes and so we
did you know go through a fine go
through the fine-tooth comb we did spend
the weekends and nights going through
saying okay what what else can we get
out of it we're not going to rewrite it
we're not going to add more to it but
how deep do we need to go in ourselves
to get the most out of the script to get
the most out of the engine you know and
and that was uh challenging and I would
say that you know beyond what the
family's aspirations and goals were
Glenn Powell was so implicated you know
and so on the line uh for that promise
he made that that that was just in the
gumbo of what it was yeah we have the
pressure the pressure
of the family but we also have you know
three you know in this case three very
young men you know to make a film of
this size putting it all on the line it
was kind of do or die every day
um not to mention we're making this
thing at the I would say the height of
the pandemic we could have been shot
down any day there's a lot going on
there and then us to having to lead you
know the ensemble in addition to that
and set the right tone and let them know
that this is not this is not what you
thought it was you know we'll show you
what it is we bring everyone home
I'm kind of a drill sergeant myself so I
I damn near memorize the Corsair uh
manual yeah I mean like uh and anything
that was taught to me I was writing down
and studying and and I took it I mean
very much like Jesse Brown No One's
Gonna
I'm just kind of telling my story now No
One's Gonna push
me harder than I am that's got to do
with my upbringing and my insecurities
and my trauma you know so I really saw
Mr Dillard you know I mean he it was all
it was all he was a teddy bear it was
all hugs and hugs and kisses between he
and I you know
um uh but but I knew he was there and I
wasn't gonna let him down you know but
ultimately I wasn't gonna let the the
man who brought me in this down or the
spirit of Jesse Brown down so you know I
try not to
I try I I try not to take it I I take it
extremely seriously but I
there's pressure but there's also like
we are aviators you know I mean like
like neighbor aviators they're not
checking in with nobody it's Instinct
you know and a lot of the a lot of the
high stakes moments emotionally and
otherwise uh we're Instinct you know I'm
not nearly I'm nowhere close to uh
brother Powell in an aircraft but I do
have Instinct you know and I do listen
you know and I go okay
do it like that that's exactly how I'm
gonna do it I'm going to make sure every
time I do it exactly like that and there
nobody can save you nobody can save you
when you're in there yeah I mean and
between action and cut nobody can get in
there and do it for you so advisors and
friends and family I view them all as a
deep deep deep deep support you know and
motivation one of the things that I love
about flying more than anything is
accountability yeah you are the pilot in
command when you're up there and it's
accountability to your wing man it's
accountability to all those things and
to be across from a guy who you know
Jonathan Majors is going to be
accountable for every moment on that
screen that guy will not let you down
that is one of the greatest things you
can be across from that's a true wingman
because again the nature of flight is
freedom but true Freedom comes from
discipline and accountability bar we
should stop that just stop that boom
oh man this sounds great
[Music]